i already did like 20 seconds of cardio
to that [ __ ] song brother it's
in the house what's up my brother what
up baby how you doing you know trying to
put the pieces together over here with
lisa what this what's what's the tweet
don't worry about tweets put the [ __ ]
phone away what's going on with you
[ __ ] um i have like three seconds
left no you're all right that's what see
you lose when you this [ __ ] guy eats
a little piece of mushroom and right
away he starts walking around like
[ __ ] like uh who turned on jesus uh
judas judas no you're fine it's fine
frank you're going to go into a natural
you're going to go into a natural
evolution we gave you the [ __ ]
gummies remodel to tame the [ __ ]
mushroom down and then we got the star
coming at you like uh the big black
kahuna
sounds good then i'll be great yeah what
are you dealing with
so you do the three triple effect you
got the mushroom menu a little something
from the hash off and those goomies are
mono right and a little piece of the
star you're not gonna eat a holster i
just don't need a little piece oh good
mixes and it's like you're on the ocean
[ __ ] floating you know what i'm
saying it's like you're in the back up
thing of uh
oh we always remember they were doing it
all the time the time now now i know why
you told me to have my will ready when i
left today i told you he called me like
20 minutes before i was gonna leave he
said make sure you have the wheel ready
tell the wife and i gotta talk to her
give her a hug because we're going deep
we're doing this ripple [ __ ] death
how was your weekend
it was good it was really good i um
the wife was gone so i just kind of hung
around and went to ra show on saturday
and brea
golf all over the house all over the
house yeah when the wife's gone that's
what happens you just start running
mister you missed the [ __ ] yeah yeah i
missed her a little bit but i haven't
had a weekend to myself in a while so
they're nice too then yes sometimes you
do some writing spend some time with red
tube you went to the gym
yeah i went to the gym every day some
push-ups yeah you're beautiful you look
good thanks i'm trying to bless you it's
gonna be hard tonight with all these the
munchies still get me again you gotta
[ __ ] the the the [ __ ] little
psilocybin mushroom the speed from it
that natural little [ __ ] thing you
shouldn't be hungry just draw a [ __ ]
coffee down and roll a joint
and you'll be back like [ __ ] i
shouldn't be hungry but the amount of
with the amount of edibles you put in me
what hunger there's no such thing what's
up my brother brent oh you don't man the
[ __ ] disco inferno that was a great
song oh sos man yeah sos band put out
like [ __ ] six jams in a row
that were tremendous i'm like in
84 like the greatest summer of music in
new york i went to see him with some
you know medium place a lot of black
people tremendous in harlem somewhere
who the [ __ ] knows uh i just heard the
song on the radio the other day in the
chat cashing stores
no it killed me when i heard that song
on the video killed me like it just put
a hole in my heart i hadn't heard it in
a while and it was one of those songs
that
you know we were just bopping to last
night went out to dinner right and we uh
kelly ronnie was there a bunch of us are
there and kelly running we were talking
about a story with how her uncle used to
hide his blow under her crib
in those little things so you could if
the cops came in so one night i was
downstairs doing my thing banging out
[ __ ] boulders like in boulder and i
kept having to go upstairs and pick her
up in the crib while she was sleeping
take the coke rocks out and put it back
in i did that all night like every hour
on the hour was [ __ ] horrible i was
terrible those days
but she went out to dinner with us it
was very nice it was very nice thank you
and it was it was fun just because
i had seen her she was there when we
filmed the documentary yeah
and then just to hear her tell the
stories of
of
seven people in a basement all like four
guys and then you would have girls over
and then you would have to go upstairs
and take the coke out of her crib and
she's just sitting there saying it while
she's eating some chicken [ __ ] crazy
we all live downstairs me her uncle her
two uncles
how old is she now she's 33 or something
34. this is all went down the summer of
84.
i had lived there since 81.
i knew them since grammar school but i
had you know she was born
uh
what she was a baby's mama you know she
was born to some guy at a bar and then
the mother married the dude and the dude
died about four years ago he was a good
[ __ ] dude here ex marina used to call
him rambo
good [ __ ] people good [ __ ] people
you know so
uh kelly was here from uh another friend
of ours becky
my wife the baby and lee you know
[ __ ] the baby goes nuts she just runs
dog
you gotta plan her outings i know
exactly she'll eat get entertained and
she's got [ __ ] to do she's gotta check
around the wrist my nieces are like they
just yeah they just take off
yeah such a great age too where you just
you know
do whatever you want so it's a [ __ ]
living reality show in front of me every
day i see a dancing before
some spanish videos one she knew the
words she was dancing she was doing the
hand movements
it's pretty [ __ ] funny to see my wife
is knocking it out with us so god bless
the both of them they're having a great
time they went to the zoo and took the
thing like yes she has the zoo pass for
the [ __ ] year uh-huh so they go to
the zoo on wednesdays they got nothing
to do they just drive to the zoo for two
hours who's better than you yeah they
seen the gorillas last week yeah but it
was crazy because she would just she was
sitting there and then she would come up
to you and take her hand and she just
paraded you around the restaurant yeah
she's like let's go there's nothing
funnier than seeing joey as long as a
two-year-old around a nice steakhouse
and she grabs your finger and she's like
come
on you just gotta go that's it you can't
fight her in the heck the show we went
outside we walked [ __ ] 10 minutes it
was just great went to uh sacramento
this week i want to give some shots are
you at the punchline [ __ ] yeah that's a
great pc week great club both punch
lines are just designed oh perfectly uh
star dome said what's up they don't want
to hire me what are you talking about i
want to go in there i want to go down
there they love you i want to go to
alabama yeah dude i just came back
that's the place birmingham
you go down there that's my first time
man i haven't been i haven't been back
there since the vince vaughn tour
really yeah and it's beautiful
yeah man [ __ ] the room is like a
theater the way it's set up and you know
it's it's cool it's intimate but it's
you know you get about 400 something
people in there it's nice
good times man anywhere in the south is
a good time with me though i'm a little
dirty
so after 18 minutes they realize who
they are where they're from yeah it
takes and they tighten up a little bit
and it's tough to work with for a few
days you start beating your [ __ ] self
up
you're like why am i eating [ __ ]
and they and they like they're little
chatty they're chatty and then after the
show they'll come up you can go that was
the best song i've ever seen you sit
there and go what the [ __ ] you talk
through the whole [ __ ] thing and
you'll stare at me like can you notice
when that happens because i just talked
about that on my podcast oh please it
really bugged me when i was at that when
i was at the show this weekend these
people thought they were at a bar
during our show during our show and they
just would not they were switching seats
it was somebody's birthday and they were
all the way in the back and the breath
and the that place is a big club
but then the club didn't do anything
about it and i i just moved seats
because i just couldn't pay attention
like they were so loud i couldn't hear
the comics dude uh yeah it's people i
don't know what the [ __ ] they're
thinking man it just it's it's gotten
progressively worse i think since i mean
i've been doing it almost 17 18 years
now and from when i first started to now
it seems like crowds tend to be a lot
more chatty the clubs the younger
younger people too the clubs come and
talk to you know like what do you want
us to do what what do i want you to do i
don't want you to take somebody and
throw them the [ __ ] out or yeah i don't
want to be okay the common behavior is
you're there
you're laughing listen you're gonna have
to talk you think why do you think i
don't [ __ ] go to comedy close i think
i didn't go to climate club because you
got to sit there like a mute for an hour
and 30 minutes
try that chill you know you can't do
that people are going to talk
different between talking
between not having [ __ ] class yeah
well there's a difference between
talking and being disruptive that [ __ ]
you see in our show that's probably
because they gave away free tickets oh
okay and they have no value involved in
the [ __ ] tickets so they go there and
jump and left people who pay a hard 22
they're not going to go to get thrown
out yeah or make noise it's it's really
weird what you see
you know
it's embarrassing
when
people are [ __ ] trying real hard i
don't think they're giving ari's tickets
away anymore
that was great with the [ __ ] stern
thing wasn't it yeah it's the prayer
improv yeah yeah the brand probably
always gives away tickets when you sell
out and that's what they haven't out
yeah they don't give up well we gave
away two for once yeah we were talking
about lee and i how every time i go to a
club
saturday night i always give you the
first one sold out saturday night has
had 150 on monday when i worked brea man
we got to go to
couples.com and give away what are you
talking about the guy was dropping his
pants on friday night with that squad
they're stoners they don't they don't
even get the [ __ ] meant until
solitude saturday
joey diaz isn't brave so this [ __ ]
[ __ ] down there was dropping his pants
on monday two for once really quick
talking about stoners when i did weeds i
did two episodes of weeds right
i got hit up by a guy that was like hey
man you wanna it was 4 20 or something
and you want to go to dc and smoke we're
having and we wanted people from you
know and i had like a little guest star
i played an armenian guy that killed her
husband i don't know if you've ever seen
the show you ever watched the show yeah
a long time yeah yeah yeah well yeah you
know you would so it's not like you know
it was a good good role
but you know what year was it uh see end
of season two beginning of season three
that was the best years of that that's
when i was in the kitchen with the great
one
after that that show had all the
potential to be one of the greatest
shows of all time early on but the funny
part was they asked me a week before
they wanted me there like like oh hey
man you know i'm like dude it's [ __ ]
short notice you know like i can't get a
ticket but even if you did you don't
smoke weed no i don't so you don't know
well you know what's crazy i i was
telling my father you smoke a shitload
man and uh i used to have to pick the
seeds out as a kid for him you know
because i had little fingers he'd be
like take the seeds out right and uh now
i mean that's why i was always wondering
how those buds work but i guess you have
the grinder thing that's that i like
listen i take this [ __ ] apart with my
fingers that's part of the old school
weed that's how they use old school i
take my own two papers i glue them
together i rip half of it that's part of
the karma that's part of the full potois
that makes you become one with the
[ __ ] reefer
you crack open this [ __ ] reefer
you're so awesome i can't even but the
shit's stronger now right sure like you
know this is the power it's so tightly
packed you can't even pop it no that had
a piece of ash in there this is isis
hash
what's that now i'm gonna make your head
pop out and then i got this [ __ ] right
here you don't have to cut your head off
you take a hit of that your head just
pops
and you got this [ __ ] but it's too wet
to crack up with your fingers so i let
it dry tonight tonight i take this home
and i put in a piece of paper i put in
the [ __ ] draw a wooden draw and when
i get up in the morning it's nice and
dry like i like it it just goes ah i
take that hash i crunch that hash up i
make a master mix
like the dj whatever in 84. dj funk
masterful i put that [ __ ] pipe
in my balcony in the back and i sparked
that [ __ ] savage up and by 7 15 i'm
dropping now like tomorrow i gotta go
for a blood test i'll get stoned
to the gills before that [ __ ] blood
test i throw that whole [ __ ]
denomination off blood's going to be
green
that's the point but see here's the
thing lee if you didn't get the seeds
out right if they smoke it that [ __ ]
would pop it blows up okay yes blows up
it stops lighting i remember one time i
had weed that somebody crushed the seeds
and put it back in the weed to put the
weight to it yeah try to [ __ ] rip you
off because usually people sell you the
weed with the seeds but if there's too
many seeds you'll complain
these people took the seeds out and then
rolled it back when you rolled it
every 10 minutes every 10 seconds the
joint would turn off
yeah it turns off every 10 seconds so
when they say it's healthier now right
you just smoke with like the humidifiers
and stuff over the paper right yeah but
then we get the [ __ ] if you're walking
on nice you might as well dance you know
what i'm saying
i'm going to smoke you know when you go
to these doctors that's the person they
say well do you have this
and that's great to smoke with the vape
and i encourage it
but what they do is they throw the
[ __ ] kids off there's too much
confusion right i smoke with death
everybody's trying to be johnny cool
just roll the [ __ ] joint and shut
your [ __ ] mouth right well they're
trying to act like you're healthy i mean
you're right just own it if it's just
not it's not healthy
yeah they were smoking that [ __ ] with a
paper and when jesus at the last supper
then they smoked that woodstock if it
worked for them it's going to work for
you but everybody wants to be johnny
cool no i have this device i have this
device all right
how are you lee what's going on in your
world i can already feel it no but it's
supposed to be feeling at least so
what's going on you were hearing a
[ __ ] siren no i'm not seeing [ __ ] you
didn't eat enough why don't you go take
a look at charlotch bronson and see if
that [ __ ] you want to eat half the
star to tame you down a little bit it's
that time i'm cool man no no no you need
a half a stop like a little [ __ ] he's
going to kill you lee yeah
i'm aware this is a 25 million but by
the time when you first started working
there you had a full head of hair and
abs pretty much
he's got you on the uncle joey
transformation diet please don't oh
look at this
look at that that's nothing
what do you mean there's nothing no no
you're gonna eat this in your sleep
by the way the fact that he put it in
his mouth and then threw it on the table
and you're gonna throw it in your mouth
now before i came in and breathed out
you didn't call me and told me that you
wanted to finger somebody's a girl's
[ __ ] and then make her sniff it and
lick it
he thought that was hysterical today
huh eat the [ __ ] thing well you don't
worry about the chick with the [ __ ]
in the finger what are you talking about
why would i take a chicken's finger and
make a smell of finger that's dude
that's please beef dog [ __ ] that's why i
over here how old are you again 26.
jesus christ you know what i was doing
dude
yeah
at 26 i was throwing a kilo eating 22
miles he's got it easy ah he's kidding
he's eating [ __ ] three little stars
like that
it's that suge night shirt he's wearing
that dude that was brilliant
his [ __ ] hands are shaking
why are your hands shaking
no i didn't even know they were i'm
scared to even ask
you're with family awesome what do you
think we're gonna shoot you i didn't
even know them i didn't even know
oh my god hysterical
so what's uh what's that joe what's up
what's going on man we're gonna play
some music or what just trying to put
the pieces together you know every
[ __ ] monday starts a whole new week
i'm home for four weeks that's good i
mean i gotta go to san diego and [ __ ]
that's like a second home
but uh not for me i don't like thursday
nights in san diego i go only go down
four where are you going to mad house
are you doing a store the other one
american county american comedy that
place is great man it's a great room but
you know i
like the store i love the store you're a
la jolla guy too yeah i mean la jolla
and then you know i know i've done that
american comedy club that's a beautiful
car i'm gonna do la jolla too the next
time i'm gonna do it or just line them
up maybe like in september what is it
now march maybe it's something what's
the matter with you looking at the
microphone nothing's the matter it's
just you're thinking about [ __ ] you're
getting anxiety in your own mind before
it even starts you already see yourself
at the hospital with a masculine he's
breathing heavy do you think i'm saying
between you and him i felt like i'm i'm
listening to a prank phone call oh
forgot like [ __ ] darth vader is
interviewing i don't have anxiety i'm
just [ __ ] high i wasn't even thinking
about anything you think you always
think i'm nervous i'm just sitting here
like when i was in the seventh grade
there was a little fat cuban kid
who wasn't all there he was half [ __ ]
[ __ ] mixed with everything else like
he's definitely in a prison
yeah
his name was orlando salcedo
and he would uh we would shoplift bubble
gum hubba bubba yeah we would go to
shoprite right behind mckinley school
and we would
shoplift bags of hubba bubba
and uh what's the other one that hubba
bubba yeah bubble yum bubble yum and
hubba bubba but one got really hard like
one turns into like a meteor i think
it's bubble you have to you too it's 20
minutes i think it's bubble yum the pink
one yeah it turns into like a [ __ ]
meteor there was a one remember they
said about spider eggs were in it
that's it that's it
this lady his name was ethel welsh
and we had maybe six savages in that
class i mean she had a kid charlie gizzy
who i knew in the seventh grade was
going to be a killer and when he got out
of high school he killed somebody well
there's always that one kid man that was
there was a little click of this this
classroom this neighborhood had dougie
jiminez who was a killer
colombo who ended up going to the
marines to kill people this class proved
but like there's always that one kid
that's stuck out like he's always
outside like that one kid with like no
adult supervision we had a couple of
them and then the cuban invasion you had
those kids that were they didn't speak
the language you know that's so weird in
miami and north bergen mckinley held
them till they were 17 in the eighth
grade until they could drive themselves
to school
then they would put them in high school
so these kids became little [ __ ]
savages but there was this one kid
orlando saying that we would go up there
and rob
and we got to be you know lunches at 12
and you got to come back at one and by
145 you'd become like a [ __ ] devil
and he would start making noises noise
and you go
wow
just every like
was he high
no with this we were too young together
we were getting high but he wasn't he
was just sit back then go wow
every like [ __ ] four minutes
wow
is that why you call me and say that to
me yeah i didn't think i said it
oh my god how can i not do it well
listen we had this kid right oh my god
listen he stole a [ __ ] ambulance man
right because this kid was out of his
tree and it's a famous story in passaic
uh i was on main avenue in front of the
quick check [ __ ] ambulance pulls up
drivers get out
matt jumps in puts the sirens on and
just [ __ ] took off man and he didn't
even go anywhere he was just doing laps
and [ __ ] right and uh uh then um the
cops like they blocked them in and then
they do they beat the [ __ ] that's what
they do
and then they threw them in the back of
the ambulance
i actually tell that story of my act man
i swear to god dude it's it was a and
it's a famous story everybody talks
about that this kid was out of his
[ __ ] tree man we had this kid in that
class we had like six killers there was
this kid in that class his name was
michael
allegretta
right off the boat from italy or cuba
italy i couldn't talk that by level and
they wouldn't talk
but we used he used to have his own
noise and he used to go
right
so orlando would be going
and then this uh with this kid why would
he make noises because it would drive
ethel welsh crazy she was like 62. the
other thing whenever we played hockey
and we hit [ __ ] uh
the italian kid in the shins
hysterically you can't write this [ __ ]
so it was him carlos zaldivar i mean it
was just alberto ali crazy after all
these years you could [ __ ] remember
oh my god because that was such a piece
of my childhood that's who you are today
as a comedian like i had the comedy of
the ali brothers here we are 12. they
were 15 him and his brother
alberto was sharp his younger brother
was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that had the face of a human but he was
a hunger
he was a [ __ ] all the way
and whatever his brother told him to do
was alberto and alfredo or something
because i told the alberto story when i
hit him in the head with the rock is
that the story you told at the coffee
shop where he threw it from the other
side of the building i hit him in the
head with the rock and he kept going i i
are you the man that means help me and
spend it he had a [ __ ] lump and a
white head in the middle i used to hit
him i used to hit him with light bulbs
that would blow up from uh do it test
but these two brothers
guys i want you to focus on this this is
how crazy you know because you try to
tell people these stories and they look
at you like okay so this guy's throwing
at me inside but tell him do you think
it's just jersey though because jersey
was a [ __ ] up place this was just
where you have this mixture the time
but these kids did [ __ ] that was just uh
you they the way they turned out and
they were hilarious our goal was to
knock mils welsh out so every afternoon
after 10 minutes of wow
she would go okay turn your books over
let's wait for meet the noise to end and
she said and she got her everybody make
noises then the whole class would just
start making sheep noises and [ __ ] and
she finally one day she just left
she was 60 something years old she could
her miss virgo were the oldest teachers
in north bergen in history wait she just
left and never came back she did a
different teacher she [ __ ] came back
she got she got lost for a while we had
mr miss we had a couple substitute
teachers at you and they tapped out too
well it was always good though to get a
when you had a sub you were we were
savages that clap richie colombo
that richard collins seen him attack
john brown in the seventh grade man
you know this is [ __ ] hard [ __ ]
kids i saw a mystic
can you explain john brown is the
teacher it's not like another student
no i know who he is saying you remember
he told the story that richie columbo
came back to kill king well he went to
the marines to teach him
baron told the story of how ten years
later he goes one day i'm at the grammar
school and i look up and here's richie
columbo that [ __ ] [ __ ]
with a marine suit on with his [ __ ]
sniper rifle looking for kingwell the
seventh grade teacher and he stopped and
goes richie what's up because i'm here
reporting for duty i'm killing earl
quinoa
richie are you [ __ ] what but what
would king will do he was just king ball
was a scumbag
okay was a seventh grade people was he
like touching kids or something no no he
smacked you and he punished and he
punched that's the other thing people
don't know you teachers used to smack
the [ __ ] out of you today this guy would
pinch your ear he would punch you in the
side he would hit you in the kidney
punch and this is what happened to him
he used to the first day of school the
last day of school you always go into
the teacher's class you're going to be
in in my school system so they tell you
who's going to be a teacher go in there
and spend an hour with him he tells you
what he expects from you blah blah blah
first thing earl king will go is all
right you have a summer assignment
so people hated them right off the bat
he was a scumbag he flicked your ears he
didn't like me i pulled the quick one on
him he did not like me by the time i got
there he already had a reputation and i
had a reputation so i let him know right
off the bat you [ __ ] touch me one
time
and my family will be here smacking the
[ __ ] out of you uh anybody who's a
history buff look it up uh what was the
guy before fidel castro
oh um i'll tell you right now batista
batista had a driver that's the one that
michael corleone had to deal with his
father's
uh batista's bodyguard was ma ding pedes
during the batista regime right before
they threw batista over they used to set
different cars with different people
and they sent like they would send me
with you in the back because you look
like batista but i'm really martin perez
and they gunned down martin perez they
shot martin perez a hundred times with
machines so did your fam your family
were batista supporters no no who the
[ __ ] knows i don't know what i'm saying
when they [ __ ] go i have no idea i'm
telling you about martin perez
martin perez lived and they put him in
north bergen with his father martin
perez used to sit on the couch like a
half a momo all day when you go with it
he wouldn't put his shirt on he'd be
smoking a cigar and you'd see the bullet
wounds through his body
but mr king will made a mistake when
they hit martin perez
and threw him out of the class at 11 at
10 to 3 you heard
and he opened the door it was martin
perez's father came out of the [ __ ]
wheelchair
really he was six foot four and he
walked and he goes i'm gonna do to jew
what'd you do to my son he beat him up
in front of the class so that ended the
reign of him hitting him in front of
people he would punch people to me he
kept breaking my balls he wanted to see
my mother
i paid this dude from the bar 50 bucks
to come down and see he would say he was
my brother and that my mother was on my
in miami on business
so the next time he's like no no
brothers this time i want to meet your
mother during my mother's meeting he
goes last time i called for you in miami
and i was like what are you talking
about
i had pulled a quick one on him my
[ __ ] mom beat me up right at the
[ __ ] school but earl king left me
back to boo okay
but it wasn't my fault it was my [ __ ] up
i was never mad at her king wolf left me
back earl king would just had a heavy
hand they like the smack kids
but a couple parents got in his face and
smacked them back people back then that
we said corporal punishment where you
know the teacher would paddle you in
front of the class i should pull my
pants down and smack your ass and we had
the uh
uh uh i meant one time um
well this is crazy too i was telling my
wife this the other day when i was a kid
my mom would send me to the store for
cigarettes you know i get a pack of
marble lights in a heart box
[ __ ] in a note you could put it on
credit yeah yeah and they just give them
a reason
come back with wine she'd pick up the
big jug that the [ __ ] guinea wine and
the and the cheap guinea one all they
have to do is call it yeah just say hey
get down there give him wine and
whatever he's gonna bring you twenty
dollars give him an ice cream
give it to him and they would they'd
sell you cigarettes well they deliver it
they deliver it i i don't you know you
put up a good question was it the
neighborhoods or
i think i don't know i had a i had a
very good time growing up and i've
always said that i had a and after my
mother died yes uh emotionally i had a
bad time but what was going on outside
me was so much laughter
that it carried me through the heart you
know what it is joe is that even when
you tell stories like you know even me
like people sometimes like where the
[ __ ] are you from i'm i mean because
some of this [ __ ] like you know my
buddy's stealing a name i try uh you
know i changed my grade i i stole the
teacher's gradebook one time that was
[ __ ] right and i and made like a 60
and 80. i mean it's a seller teaches
editions like in the second grade at ps
166
and that's why i transferred to catholic
school
yeah
you're always trying to out crazy the
next kid you always streety i was always
very streety
my mother didn't like me to be streety
but she did
she didn't want me to be nerdish either
i started out to be nerdish but i
enjoyed the other side i enjoyed how
kids knew how to make a buck when they
were six and seven
i like how kids would say they would cut
you in like listen if you help us we'll
give you a dollar we get ten dollars and
you're like are you [ __ ] sick so if i
help you carry this to this guy's house
at two in the afternoon groceries
you'll give me a dollar plus the tip
you love that either you like that or
not either you're one of those kids that
likes that or you want to go home and
play nintendo
and [ __ ] always always trying to make
money so even though i had money at home
i got to ask my mom for 20. i enjoyed
that i always enjoyed see i was doing we
had
so me and keith like my little brother
we dress up as boy scouts collect money
that was [ __ ] strong little scam we
used to crack the pay phones
on the side i don't know if you remember
like it's still there if you see him
they have like the key where the keyhole
is you smack that [ __ ] thing with a
hammer hard enough and a screwdriver
yeah the whole thing crashes
yeah and then all the change comes out
we used to do that [ __ ] all the time
[ __ ] uh uh my little brother how did
you figure that out huh how did you
figure it out
um actually i'll tell you exactly how i
figured it out um is
uh you know you check for coins right
you know you put your finger in there it
was just uh it was just hard like you
couldn't push in there and then you
would hear it rattle you understand and
all the change was in there and the the
box that they kept it in with that when
i've seen it was it was just cracked
so i don't know if some [ __ ] drug
drug addict did it and then i just
figured you know if you [ __ ] i just
try to duplicate it but then yeah if you
there's there you can just smack it we
just used a hammer but there's the
screwdriver thing you know what else i
remember is the old school uh how do you
get time on the meter i don't know if
you remember used to do this where you
would
you know the ones you put the coin in
and you turn yeah right yeah you would
hold it half mass and then smack it with
a [ __ ] shoe and then the thing would
just stick somehow we used to do that
[ __ ] all the time i had something i had
the the
we used to sell phone numbers
ago i had the the paper clip and i would
do those when i go to lowe's felice to
eat pizza that pizza place and uh
to have a cup which is selling april 1st
he sold it the only one i ever had was
you know the coke machines that have a
conveyor belt that bring it to you like
a couple years ago if you could you they
used to make it so you could put your
hand in and if you stopped it from the
coke from coming out it would think
there was a mistake so it would give you
your money back and then you could get
another one so you could get like a
bunch for the price of one and that's
the only scam i ever did some people had
like the the masking tape on the dollar
bill and you would just put it in then
rip it back out but i never tried that
one i never tried that no i mean either
we had the friend who got the bank money
deposit with a fishing line and a hook
oh wow the night depository and he got
it danny biancolo's brother i know that
was the first time he ever it's not a
good story he was about 14 and he tipped
the cab driver like 200
and that's who ratted them out the cab
driver really yeah they just called all
the cabs that went to the airport that
night and he was one of the cabs and
they said you took a kid yeah i did in
fact he tipped me 200.
here's where he's staying
now we did the um uh he did a little you
know stupid [ __ ] we used to have the
phone dialers i don't know if you had
those where
if you put up to a pay phone like i
don't know if you remember putting
change in it and it would make that
noise that click click click click click
right but it was a recording of that
noise so you would put it to the
receiver and hit it and then the phone
would read that a coin drop so that's
that was it yeah so
you would if you hit it four times and
you put a dollar in so you can make
phone calls and [ __ ] you sell them to
like the uh uh you know like the the
immigrants and stuff would use it to
call home call overseas or you know to
call international because it was like
16 17 dollars to calling long distance
on a pay phone i don't know if you
remember that [ __ ] that's what i think
that the children of today lack
like even the base the pa the basic
paper route absolutely the paper route
was the amer american way it was
something that
i remember splitting the paper out like
that's how you got a paper like i wanted
even though i knew how to make uh money
on the street doing [ __ ] up things
selling stickers from cyo basketball you
steal the stickers and you sell them and
you steal them back and
for two dollars but two dollars adds up
when you're [ __ ] 16 and 10 and 12.
two dollars times eight is 16 [ __ ]
dollars that was an album when i was
growing up that's an album that's a pair
of [ __ ] converse high tops dude
listen to this my buddy this is the
greatest scam you've ever heard it for a
kid
you know you shovel walks for cash right
there would be like five whatever
they'll pitch in five ten dollars then
they would go to the
to the um
flower shop and buy a big ass christmas
wreath
for like forty thirty forty dollars
that's you know i was in the 80s it's
like three thousand dollars today then
they were going to different
neighborhoods that didn't know them and
they would knock on the door with the
wreath
trying to sell it you know take deposits
for it and [ __ ] like for the for the
holidays you understand like you know
say oh yeah we're selling for the church
and this is this beautiful wreath and
they're only 30 bucks all you need is
like a 10 deposit and had the drop sheet
where they write their names down take
the 10 bucks and just go take deposits
for the wreath you'd be surprised how
many people you know
dude are you [ __ ] serious it's a 40
wreath that they're selling for 30 for
the church or for the school or for
whatever they came up with and you get
the 10 uh
deposit so they would get deposits from
all the houses you know nobody gets the
wreath and then if you saw an old lady
you'd give it to the old lady
people's express
that was my big one look at lee's face
it's [ __ ] red like his yeah little
[ __ ] uh daisy duke shirt what's he
gonna say it's chug night shirt nice
shirt he looks like chic light today he
really does do you do you guys ever get
a sugar night
pretty much
do you guys ever get the people in the
like
suvs they'll come up to you and they'll
be like i have speakers yes i sold those
acoustic oh my god and they always like
oh it's not on and they always have a
piece of paper
it's not on it's not on my order form
dude i can give it to you for 90. listen
to me i don't know who falls right
listen to me a lot of people
college students when i lived in
tallahassee
no no no they're speakers they're just
shitty speakers but they're there we we
you get them from california actually
back then when we were in tallahassee my
buddies were [ __ ] really good at this
and you order these they're called
acoustic speakers and they would come in
and you just pull up the gas stations
and say hey now here's the scam
you act like they're stolen and you're
trying to act like they're not stolen
but they're really not stolen does that
make any sense right so you're like
listen i had this delivery and you make
the story sound shady so people think
they're stolen and you're trying to act
like they're not does that make any
sense
but they're really not stolen you're
they're paid for they're just really bad
right i got this thing right right
absolutely i didn't make the delivery
they usually go for 100 give me 50. so
you i think at the time they were like
30 bucks a pair and you could sell them
for like 200 this was back in 91 92 but
you would order like like you know 500
worth of speakers or a thousand and you
could make triple your money almost you
know
you would they had a van to pull up in
the gas station to people and [ __ ]
happened to me last week in hollywood
and i just don't ever buy them no so but
why would you want people to think that
they're stolen because you want them to
think that it's that's you want that
that it's a good pair of st like in
other words you want them to think that
they're getting a deal
you understand but here's the problem
once you leave the east coast it's very
tough to
sell stolen
merchandise unless the person has grown
up in that culture
it's very hard people won't buy it i
tried in colorado in boulder i used to
have 30 000 rolex watches people would
look at me like i was [ __ ] crazy well
that's you know back home like even
there you would just want to buy [ __ ]
well yeah you'd see do you know a guy
that has this and then if they said no
they don't then you went to the [ __ ]
store for the [ __ ] store but that's
the that's a different time man it's
very tough to sell things you know
there's a couple movies there's a movie
called with a family business
with uh
uh
dustin hoffman and matthew broderick and
sean connery and they play an irish
family that are thieves but in that
movie they have a reoccurring character
that just sells [ __ ] every time you see
that guys excuse me
i got some vince verragamo shoes 300 up
and down madison boulevard i got him for
you for a hundred bucks what are you
nine [ __ ] d like he knows foot sizes
you see him at the bar you see him at
wakes he shows up to the wake at the
wake he's like
you see like guys come in with a [ __ ]
you know with uh whatever and they're
like coming up to him like how are you
doing all day long sorry yeah sorry give
priests father how you doing listen i
got vince ferragamo shoes 80 off up and
down the boy he's got the same rap for
everything my uncle boy he's he's not my
uncle i say he's my uncle because he
grew up you know it's like anything you
know what we do cousins uncles we some
of them uh but he he had a i went by the
house
and uh he was my grandfather's best
friend
and he he goes and he goes hey have you
seen the new paris hilton video right
and i said uh no
come with me he opens the [ __ ] he's
got all these remember the paris hilton
when she had sex that sex tape he had
all the [ __ ] dvds in there and he
goes here take one then he goes what
size are you ah ten and a half [ __ ]
head shoes left with a plate of [ __ ]
rigatoni i'm like that's only in my
family you leave with porn [ __ ] shoes
and and [ __ ] nice little plate of
food when i was taking it there was a
family in north bergen
who i was fond of them but not really
like they had four kids and two of them
were cool the other two were like
they knew what the father did yeah but
as we got older the brother came are
they the jerk-off guy that's like you
know my father yeah they used to [ __ ]
yeah yeah but the oldest one was really
the real deal as a human being to the
point where
there's people stay away from the oldest
one and he's not involved in anything no
family he's just out there he did time
for murder in a car
i mean when we were kids he used to
really see the devil
on blow and if you put aerosmith on he
would
lose your mind
and he ended up going to prison for
running over somebody and i remember in
94 we'd be playing basketball and he'd
be on a bicycle like part of the deal
for him together was like listen you
can't even have car keys on you
so he's always on a bicycle which made
him get in good shape but whenever he
drive past us on a bicycle people would
just freeze like it's frankie and they
would just freeze so he wouldn't see
like debo on friday yeah like he was
that scary not big
or
whatever but every the point being when
i was about at 17 i got into gambling
and somebody goes calling
he says you could put bets on them every
time you went down they collect there
was always a story yeah
and there was always a
what size of you come on out to the
garage the garage guys
it was tough to close the garage
like he would have to push things in and
close the garage door and they would
land again he would have to put his foot
he had two of those and in those two
garages he had one of everything
you name it one of everything and it was
one size left like it was the bottom of
the shipment
but he held on to it till the end
somebody would just go come here give
this to some kid on this homeless no no
no no i remember leaving this like
beating them for 300 gambling but
leaving with a hundred because now i got
a leather jacket that's a 2x even though
then i wasn't i was only like an l right
but he talked you into it that's how
good he was there's those type of people
that just have
[ __ ] out of their house i remember 94 my
stepdad took me to these buildings in
west new york
where the people would rent apartments
and basically it was just hot stuff
clothes and blenders and everything was
in boxes and i mean [ __ ] six seven
hundred dollar real [ __ ] suits
remember that's how i got started
selling cars he took me to this thing
and i spent like two thousand dollars
and i got three tremendous suits and
like five all the [ __ ] shoes with the
thick soles real [ __ ] communist shoes
not that [ __ ] you're gonna pay less and
you think you've all they're italian
[ __ ] whatever that's an italian [ __ ]
look at the shape of that [ __ ]
mortadella
what's up dog [ __ ] is going on nothing
i'm good man i know you're good but why
is your face all red talk to me what do
you mean what's my face what do you feel
right now close your eyes i feel really
[ __ ] good
adele
oh my god i'm sure you feel good i gave
you
the magic you know how many people live
to get this combination we should we
should most people don't live after that
jersey stories jersey store south
florida stories are [ __ ] up too man
it's a crazy area that's [ __ ] always
been crazy down there and that's where
people go
when they're just too crazy they're
losing everything was drugs man yeah
everything is drugs everything like
everything is drugs steroids ecstasy
drugs uh well uh coke
uh like you know that's all like that's
just oh like i mean well in my high
school there was a lot of steroids and
[ __ ] but
you know i uh but it was it's a
different time everything's changed man
it is it doesn't seem like
little kids hustle like they used to man
i mean we were always hustling washing
cars in boston a couple kids got
arrested because they were shoveling uh
they're going around traveling driveways
and some people gotta got mad can you
believe that that's crazy can you
believe that that's how the kid does and
and
a kid in my position when i was that age
and i'm not
embarrassed to say this i was very
spoiled my mother if i just asked her my
dad had died right so she said that you
were like cartman right whatever i
wanted it just took me a week to get you
were cuban cartman and uh i never really
had to do half the things i did at that
age but i enjoyed them
when i used to go to 148th street i'd
see these kids and they inspired me they
had you know i had a air conditioning in
my room these kids lived in a room with
their mothers and fathers in the living
room
thrown around the [ __ ] floor you know
the the bedroom was for clothing and you
know they had one
and i couldn't even tell them how i
lived they'd ask me i'd be embarrassed
to tell them because
but they taught me they they inspired me
that you had to move every day and you
had it and i never forgot their hustle
they always shook down somebody but
legitimately they weren't bad kids like
they just tell you the truth you know at
night when you leave and you're in
staten island sleep
your window we're going to protect your
[ __ ] window mm-hmm you know they were
different kids and i never i forgot
their names over the years
but they taught me that gift and that's
what kids are lacking today that they
don't really what's even more crazy is
like a grandparent like my grandfather
you know they were my he he was uh doing
construction at like 12 man he was
driving trucks because you didn't you
know driving down the dirt roads back
then my family you know they were all
from jersey city
and uh uh and uh you know when they were
younger man you know they all worked my
grandfather you can get past six sixth
grade i think what was the first time
you got behind the seat of a car uh i
well i stole i was in a stolen car in
middle school
um but we used to these these two
brothers uh
alan vinnie what what are you doing
nothing so they just felt
nothing just something off the mic stand
real quick he looks like his lips are
[ __ ] falling off yeah it feels like
it he's hammered no alan vinnie they
they had this mail truck that they took
and they rebuilt it like this this the
kid like that had the mini bike that he
they could build everything typical
guineas with you know the grease monkeys
they fix everything right so we had a a
mail truck
that we used to drive around in
um but it was on the you know the other
side so the first time i learned what is
it with mail trucks and then why you had
a mail truck too to [ __ ] around no no
well they used to be at the dump at the
jump show at the jump at the at the dump
and then you would take it and they
could fix it up start it and go but the
funny thing is is that i've been driving
since i was like 11 or 12 but when my
mother tried to teach me how to drive i
had to act like i didn't know how you
know she's like i'm going to teach you
when i want to get my prior already
known how were you when you got behind
the i'm 15 16. yeah i was i was
petrified you didn't tell us no no i
didn't want to i had no need for it i
didn't want i didn't like cars i wasn't
attracted to
and cars when my mother died i used to
hang out with this dude from time to
time his name is mike denny and his
father owned
a ship reconstruct contracting company
so when your ship came into town they
went in
they painted all the garbage they took
the barnacles off your ship they
put rustoleum on they rebuilt the floors
with the water was leakage with uh
that special kind of plywood
and they did everything at night
so they got really busy and i used to
hang out with mike
it's called the devil when he was a kid
they call him the devil you know where
the devil is today what's his last name
denny mike denny today he's in a prison
in north carolina for killing his wife i
mean this guy because i knew a kid from
patterson with that nickname this kid
was the [ __ ] devil when we were kids
from right around he was right around my
block there in north bergen and they
came through and then goes listen
my father needs help and he really likes
you he knows your mom died you know how
to drive you want to drive with us at
night and i'm like i can't drive a stick
so from six to ten i drive to hoboken
pier
i go to newark pier and i just drop off
little things you know you just [ __ ]
drove you never mind
he taught me how to drive after two
weeks i said i'm scared i don't want to
do it no more he goes
jesus [ __ ] christ
and he called his brother who had a
driving school like down the shore the
brother came didn't check any paperwork
and just gave me a driver's license just
like [ __ ] that gave me this thing is
like don't worry i think it's 16 and a
half you get a learner's permit 16 you
get a permit
oh yeah new jersey florida it's 15 and
then 16 to drive in new jersey 16 to get
a permit 17 to drive that's too [ __ ]
young you're still [ __ ] wet behind
the ears no one of these kids [ __ ]
die that's too [ __ ] young to give a
kid a [ __ ] did you ever get in an
accident when you were young no knock on
wood never
well you're not still young no no no no
you
like i told you guys i was never a big
car guy when i was a little kid i was
mentioned once you're not supposed to
get in strange people's cars and that's
something i live by
you know when i'm out of these places
people always hit me up hey there's a
great restaurant here there's a great
jujitsu here the first thing i say is
can i walk to it from the club
if they say no i ain't doing i don't get
in strange cars since i was a kid you
know something that was instilled in me
when i was eight and i'm 50 now i don't
need to rent the car when i'm in a
comedy town
we literally the kid that stole the
ambulance is the one that stole the car
and we were driving around we would go
joyriding all the [ __ ] time yeah i
never liked stolen cars that was a big
thing when we were kids too yeah
like jersey they used to love to steal
cars i never liked it at all yeah i know
i could tell you
i'm fine yeah i'm just not enough i
never i never understood how you wanted
to sit
in the [ __ ] evidence
yeah like that to me never made sense
like there's no getting out of that but
when you're 12. yeah they chased you i
didn't like i had a friend jose ortado
and another guys that went to robin cars
dude i would love to write a movie about
that night that what had happened there
was four of us
two of us got caught and me and my buddy
al this kid al is that he was always
like that kid like i said before he's
outside he knew he knew the streets
inside and out this kid can spot a
[ __ ] unmarked car a mile away so what
happened was we ditched it and we all
took off and my my other two friends ken
matt and steve they they they went one
way me and al went the other they ended
up getting caught but that night from
where we were to get back to to trying
to get home on the railroad tracks
it was a [ __ ] crazy night man
it's like a standby moment right the
script and suspension it's a it's a
standpoint write the [ __ ] script and
suspenses you know what i'm saying what
does ant suspensions mean keep us
suspended
every three weeks say script is coming
don't worry about nothing
well you love driving now you drive
scary like you he'll be he'll be high as
high as i am or higher
driving down the 101.
meshuggah night is all is over
tonight
i like driving because i'm driving
yeah but you do 90 and you beat the cops
better than somebody else driving you
don't know where the [ __ ] you're going
that's true let's kick some music so
don't worry about it there's a reason
there's a method for my men we got music
where's tony bennett to get this party
started it's monday night sucker
i don't want to be a wreck you get all
that
you forget about tony bennett i didn't
think yes you did [ __ ] we should
put something on for lee it's monday
45 minutes i wanna be around
it's a beautiful gym
these mushrooms are kicking in the red
devils kicking in
they've
he's melting who's jewish elvis don't
worry about neil diaz [ __ ] neil
diamond just don't wear my diamond just
[ __ ] leave tony bennett on it don't
worry about neil diamond i'm trying to
just say [ __ ] hebrew not at the shop
you know what i'm saying whatever the
shalom
shabbat shalom
it's a great song
so what do you want to put on the
[ __ ] jewish hours for leave this guy
on he ain't bothering nobody
what's up lisa [ __ ] look at the
shape here yeah you know it's a shamely
you don't even know who the jewish elvis
is it's your own people can you imagine
that this is what i got to deal with you
got
one of the dopest [ __ ] neil diamond
charles bronson they're all in the i
know who neil diamond is time to go to
[ __ ] movies and museums
company
the backbone of the jewish royals
i want you to put on donna summer and
barbra streisand oh god great summer car
park no no not macarthur park the uh put
the [ __ ] thing on donna enough is
barbra
enough
enough is enough we're going deeper let
me see if i can get on this you get on
the phone you get on it all right and
then you know it's a great song too did
you eat that style let's get another one
heaven knows is great too let's get the
[ __ ] thing here let's get barbra
streisand and get some bats going she's
jewish too you know we ain't [ __ ]
around late tonight the church or what's
happening now the speakers are off my
ears
it's over what do you got lee what do
you mean look at me this is like this is
the best i hate these commercial the
visa check card [ __ ] the visa check all
these got under control
look at least what's he doing trying to
this i'm talking about all these guys
under control dog
well you don't [ __ ] around look at this
it's not uh there's only
did this tv come out of your friend's
[ __ ] garage as well
what happened
i was hoping it was gonna be live but no
it's just it's just we don't want it
live you want this yeah that's what you
want you don't want it live this
extended
[ __ ] job kick this in the door get it
out don't forget that's the best part
are you [ __ ] kidding me five million
views let's see how many people disliked
it
nobody it's why you got five million
views yeah i always know i always that
always makes me laugh when these people
[ __ ] like i'm looking at pink floyd
and there's like a hundred this like how
did [ __ ] you dislike pink floyd because
they're [ __ ] morons they're listening
to whatever the [ __ ] who would you clip
first the jewish elvis none of them look
at these two you you're those young
faces
babs nobody nobody [ __ ] babs for
starters all right
flashes just like that and [ __ ]
up the she
donna summer was hot though remember
that movie thank god it's friday tg i
don't remember dude she was on it come
on
blast that [ __ ] lee
i'm on mushrooms
what's your favorite ever keep asking
your questions now to [ __ ] with you
so what's your favorite thing of summer
song
that's that's what it is
are you [ __ ] nuts people love
livestreams monday night irish people
are somewhere [ __ ] counting pennies
getting ready for tomorrow here we are
[ __ ] playing donna some match hey lee
what's joe's [ __ ] twitter handle
again ant-man flavor that's what it is
here comes this one it kicks in
oh [ __ ] here we go there's an education
people
you [ __ ] nuts
nate rent the re on there spitting some
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh no this is too much this is
new this is [ __ ] great this is jews
please don't touch your [ __ ]
rob oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] crocodile gundy you're nothing
get this crocodile gandy
oh [ __ ]
i almost had a [ __ ] nervous breakdown
people it's monday night the night
before saint patty's
get on your disco shoes [ __ ]
it's just starting here me and the
flying jew are going deep with another
star in a minute here it's only 9 30.
he's a five-star general
two-star two and a half star
a two star general with a little bit of
gummy germanos and mushrooms but i'm
very not in love with that i'm really
happy that uh
like when i was a kid i i did it but i
didn't want people to know but after my
mom died i had to learn how to do it
and i just put you know you learn how to
buy a hundred quail loot and sell them
for four dollars and
you know give away four to get people
enticed it's your own little personal
business
and that's what a lot of people that's
it you're 100 business then i started
getting the ups and i was getting the
ups of 40 for [ __ ] a thousand of them
and i would sell a 100 of them for 35 so
all i need to do is sell 200 and i was
already in profit i could eat 800
[ __ ] ups i didn't i [ __ ] sold them
so you learn you learn how to cut
corners you look you know uh how to
raise the price of mestling and raise
you know lower the [ __ ] price it was
just another yeah you got to dictate the
market
you had to do it then cocaine came along
and i tell you what there's so many
people i taught how to like market code
like a lot of people would grind it up i
don't want my car i want to see a rock
in there you give somebody a rock and
sometimes they'll pay the extra 50.
people want to go to the parties and go
look at the rock i got from [ __ ] joey
diaz you're following me nobody wants
that power but that carried that that
carried a lot of weight back that night
what's that the samson back then man the
whole the sentencing back there if you
get caught that [ __ ] was they they went
after it for a while they go after you
for everything in this life you know
it's
when you're stupid and you have uh you
know you have a
a cause you have something to sell it
for you don't even know why i didn't
want to [ __ ] work as a kid
i knew if i could sell an eight ball
night i had fifty dollars and i could
snort a gram of coke fifty dollars in
those days to go out with was 22 [ __ ]
cocktails a tip and white castle
well [ __ ] some place that gave you
it's still white for two dollars yeah
you know so it was a difference and were
you know yeah one one night you make 200
and that 100 went towards the rent once
a week plus your expenses you know was
it different so that's how you looked at
it i'm very happy i took that education
and i applied it later on you know as i
was it kept me up jesus christ had to
borrow from peter the people
it's a horrible way to [ __ ] live
but sometimes you gotta do it and i did
that for years you know starting comedy
is not easy
when you first start comedy it is
[ __ ] hard absolutely and once you
make the decision to do comedy full-time
there's a lot you know and i didn't want
to get that day job i i really had that
stupid [ __ ] artist dream where you
sit in your loft there was no loft i had
a car with air conditioning thank god
you know and uh
and there's a lot of times i could have
i didn't work
and there's a lot of times that i worked
two i worked all the way to the end i
saw cigars on sunset
i sold [ __ ] cigars on sunset one side
because i got here in 97 the boom was a
guard oh yeah yeah so they were selling
cigars all along did you have a hook up
in cuba
no no i sold cigars for a [ __ ] store
all right guess what cuba
i'm trying to be a comic fifteen dollars
a spot you think i'm making calls to
cuba get brothers and fathers get some
cohibas in there [ __ ] little illegal
swag the story on the street i'm sorry i
guess i was out of line yeah we knew
something yeah you're selling [ __ ]
quaaludes and and
but uh at the time i was i guess you
can't sell a cigar at the time i was on
sunset trying to be a comic so i didn't
i wasn't really selling anything i had
just moved here i was sleeping on the
floor and that was what was available to
me without a car
was selling cigars on sunset that's
before i met any drug people i started
slinging little coke here and there
so but i hit a taco bell commercial for
80 grand
my first year here so i stopped the
cigar business but the cigar business
was great i knew a lot of comics were
selling cigars there was two places
there was one by hoy's walk on the
second floor you know where hoy's walk
is on sunset lebron yeah it was like and
it's still a cigar store downstairs yeah
yeah it's still a cigar store they sold
the guy upstairs made millions that's
when jj's beepers were here
jj's beepers was who's the hooker that
went to jail with uh what's his name
what's the phone
heidi fleiss heidi fleisch he was heidi
fleisch's partner when you [ __ ] came
to la those days there was a bunch of
[ __ ] beepers there was a bunch of
billboards that said jj's beeper the
king of beeper with 7.99 they got a
beeper he was my main man i loved him
right behind hoy's walk right there then
the other cigar shop was two blocks up
by the hotel what's the crack hotel
across from rock and roll ralph's
sahara it's a sahara once you pass the
sahara there's a street that makes her
right right there on the corner there's
a there's a photography place right on
top wasn't there a place across the
street from the store or is that always
i mean that's been there since i i mean
i think i got a house of blues no it's
to the left of that there's a cigar bar
right there so going no no no that's
just that that just came out yeah no no
this is when you would call remember
when you would go to bodegas in harlem
and you'd see [ __ ] a case with cigars
who do you think sold those [ __ ]
cigars some [ __ ] guy across the
street from the comedy store no us
savages
in [ __ ] in l.a that we would just
call people hey man we have started
sampling kids everybody wants a cigar
right yeah you got cigars there no we're
gonna send you a humidifier it was no
humidify it was a glass [ __ ] case for
400 bucks but if you sold one of them
they gave you like 180.
i'd sell three of those a day and get to
hit the bonus you get 50 cash and i was
at the comedy store to get chewie chewie
yeah
let me talk to him okay park here bro
let me talk to you about something just
[ __ ] you bro what kind of deal you got
going on here yeah yeah the [ __ ] good
business come on how many packages 20. i
got 40. that's two-pack why i can't get
three from me you get pissed off leave
me alone joey
what's up he had a good business going
to that guy how you feeling over that
[ __ ] i'm good can't park here bro
you know you need to
and that's what i see that these guys
they don't know how to put and i'm not
talking about selling drugs
you know in and when i got divorced when
i got divorced let me put it to you as
well when i got divorced
in boulder i worked for
my ex-wife's family how long were you
married
two years it was a failure it was a
failure but i worked for them and for
some reason all the companies then that
they did business with offered
a free estimating class
so i would call the people this is how
slick i was bro at 20 [ __ ] whatever
even though i was the next foul and [ __ ]
i would call these companies and go hey
man i'm a roofer
i'm an apprentice but i want to learn
how to estimate they would fly me out
3m and all those companies would fly me
out and teach me how to
estimate that type of [ __ ] oh because
they wanted you to use their products
but i also started learning
slanted roofs and all those shingles and
[ __ ] so i went through a couple of their
things
and one day i was by my friend's house
and he's like hey man can you get your
brother to come over here after the hail
storm nobody came to this [ __ ] house
so right away my drug mentality went up
i'm like what is that and i measured it
i did what this the regular people
around me would charge it was like two
thousand dollars
when i added up the material it was like
[ __ ] six hundred dollars
so i'd make 1400
somebody else give him 500 rip the top
off with him
the dumpster was a deuce throwing a
dumpster
that's how mad that's how much the
gambinos control construction
a dumpster
anywhere else in the united states of
america was two hundred dollars for
those regular dumps as you see that
people come up and pick up
you know how much that same dumpster was
in new york city in 1985. how much 2200
that's how much went into sammy the
bull's pocket i know yeah he controlled
all the construction controls all the
[ __ ] construction because i met my
brother-in-law's company who left new
jersey to go to colorado they were like
you have no idea what the construction
costs are on the east coast because of
that [ __ ] mafia
you have no idea
but i would go into a neighborhood with
a box of flies
pass them around the [ __ ]
neighborhood
by the time i got home and i had three
calls already when i was going back to
measure their houses
people walk over to me and go how can
you measure my house
i go over i pull a [ __ ] bread and
just get a 500 deposit
and tell them i'd be here the week of
the 20th and i'd show up and do the roof
i was making [ __ ] a thousand bucks on
a saturday what did i get
i busted my ump a little bit but i
didn't have any options then i had no
[ __ ] options i had no
i had a degree but it wasn't going to do
nothing i had a felony i couldn't do
nothing right so it always comes in that
street hustle
what was your first pinch
january 26th of 1983.
i was as an adult property
yeah i never took a
juvenile not nothing not even a talking
to not even a cop coming to the house
a cop uh
dropped me off one night when he found
me in some guy's yard passed out
puking
uh
i had that type of contact but never a
jewelry record whatsoever that's what
they get you for
possession of stone property
when you have tools to rob somebody
oh yeah like like the burglar tools like
i had like a pen
like it was did they trump it up or were
you gonna use it to break into something
no i uh
i was gonna break into something yeah i
had something no i had i had check books
and i gave them to somebody and that was
my plea bargain too
i think it was a 500 bail it was my
first is it misdemeanor mr mean and i
went did the probation then i got
arrested shortly after that
for smoking pot
after the redskins
super bowl beat the raid opens are the
dolphins yeah that i think 83. yeah yeah
no that was it 82 82 83 kilo b's yeah
yeah i won 800 went into the city in the
winter that was [ __ ] wind was blowing
i went into a corner i bought some
chocolate thai stick at one of those
health food stores
and i went into a corner the mailman put
a gun to my head that was my second
pitch
done about two weeks [ __ ] was the
mailman putting a gun in here he was
making a citizen
because there was a scrambling school
then somebody was selling loose joints i
just happened to go that one in the
afternoon it was
guys i'll never forget how cold it was
and i was in that corner the tears were
frozen on my face and he threw me on the
[ __ ] floor and they
threw away my papa gave it back to me
like so i had 14 grams
they threw like four grams away and gave
me the bag back
they pinched me that time then right
before i left for colorado
i got pinched for uh
stolen tools
trying to break into somebody's house
and they caught me on the way out we
didn't get in
they caught me on foot but then they
threw it out
i knew somebody in union city something
they threw it out and then i just wanted
a string of [ __ ]
but when i went to colorado no i didn't
get arrested the guy had contact at the
end
that was night i robbed the jewelry
store i didn't get in
but it was a snow storm brother this is
how much of a genius i was
and i walked back i seen the cops coming
to get me so i jumped and walked in all
these snow things
and i went to my house and i went in and
i took my clothes off and i relaxed and
about an hour later the door knocks and
there's 20 cops in my door i'm like
excuse me have you been out tonight i'm
like no
and they look by the radio and there's
my boots melting with snow
so they knew it was me who robbed the
jewelry store they just didn't have
proof i knew they were going to come
back
by the time they came back i boogied and
then i probably went through
ten arrests that were just uh you know
hanging out with dude my this is sad
well it's not sad i don't know what you
want to call it but my a good friend of
mine was 18 years old and uh first
offense that game 10 years man he got
caught with uh acid
but in the state of florida each each
hits a count of manslaughter
can you imagine that i know and he had a
hundred i think it's like a hundred on
the sheet oh yeah
and he had a hundred i had a hundred on
a sheet and i think ten sheets
so they got a thousand counts yeah a
thousand counts of manslaughter man and
they just [ __ ]
and that only gets 10 18 maybe there may
be 100 sheets yeah i give thanks every
day i give you people think i'm
bullshitting it but he went from 18 to
28 man he spent all of his 20s in prison
you people think that i i [ __ ] i get
up in the morning i give thanks for
my daughter i give thanks for mercy i
give thanks for
the friends i have you know i give
thanks for uh
the career like how it worked out you
know i never wanted to be eddie murphy i
just wanted to be alive
and i got that i just wanted i didn't i
don't care if my pictures at the improv
none of that [ __ ] mattered to me i just
want to let [ __ ] knew i was
here and i didn't have caa i didn't have
three arts and i was here i did what i
had to do
and i give thanks that i never got
involved like when i got locked up
people went to a bodybuilders
i say something to your girlfriend
you take a swing at me and i die
and you got involuntary manslaughter
you're going to have 12 years of your
life and guess what
they're going to put your section to
prison
okay
so now you got 12. that means you're
looking at eighth all right that you got
to do
you're 19 you're home on spring [ __ ]
break right you were just with your high
school girlfriend looking to get your
dick sucked you didn't know she was
sucking 20 other dicks right she didn't
tell you that in the [ __ ] postcard
they never do
you know we want to hook up and relive
our times they didn't tell you how they
[ __ ] the puerto rican and the coke
dealer at the bar and some guys got
pictures of them and you show up happy
henry like [ __ ] yeah yeah thinking
that's good here's my name my little
angel and here comes johnny bananas at
the barn you gotta knock him the [ __ ]
out do you ever think about like what
would have happened if you had killed
those people that's what we're getting
to right now so they give you eight
[ __ ] years eight out of twelve
you do eight while you're in there
somebody gets a b for you yeah now you
gotta attack another six i've seen that
so you're going at [ __ ] 20 and you're
coming at 36. do you have any [ __ ]
idea
do you have any [ __ ]
any [ __ ] idea i had a little
semblance by the time i went in i was
28. i had i had an idea who i was yeah
yeah and who i wanted to be do you
understand what i'm trying to say to you
when you grab a person with the mind of
a child and they're at 18. i'm not
saying he's getting raped that's not
what i'm talking about i'm talking about
he has to make decisions yeah
what he's going to learn in there the
first tattoo
the first
the first hey man that's cool yeah
that's it society's got him now he comes
out when he's 36 years old who the
[ __ ] gonna hire him
so what do you think he's gonna do you
know he developed the [ __ ] habit in
the prison
you know
i'm very lucky lee never mind those
people died i'm very lucky there was 30
other [ __ ] situations that i walked
into that jesus [ __ ] christ
jesus [ __ ] christ and i'll sit there
some nights and go
can you [ __ ] imagine
what if
what [ __ ] if peop me going to parties
and you getting hit and i stick up for
you and punch somebody in the [ __ ]
head what if that guy just died what if
that guy just had a brain aneurysm no
dude you have no [ __ ] idea that's not
that's not far-fetched and i'm telling
you this is not i tell you when i get
locked up when i got locked up i bumped
into
30 [ __ ] kids that were just
living
they thought they were just living your
friend
he bought a hundred hits of acid god
knows what he was gonna do he ain't no
[ __ ] terrorist he ain't no bad person
he was just an eighteen-year-old kid
right that the priest that they looked
at state sachin sanctions for and they
never looked at this kid and said maybe
he's just a [ __ ] he needs four years
to scare him a little bit and we'll
re-sentence him depending on how he does
after two no there's a state man and he
was a nice kid nice kid and
doug they go in they don't recover from
that well he he was lucky though he went
to minimum or medium they they did that
for him and then you know he came out
he's got his [ __ ] together um but you
know he talks to people now
he talks to kids and stuff and tells
them because you know you do you're in
that you can make such a bad decision at
that age that's why i mean even now with
these [ __ ]
cameras everybody's filming people's
childhoods like god forbid that there
was cameras on me when i was 20 21. can
you imagine oh my god man
it would be insane dude if there was a i
wish there was a video of uncle joey at
[ __ ] 20 21
get do it dancing in a club i would pay
eight million dollars for that video
right now
lee what about you which uh your bar
mitzvah video is there uh any crazy [ __ ]
going on not like that not like that i
shoplifted but i didn't do anything
crazy like you guys
did you light a candle for somebody even
in the bar mitzvah video you know how
many bar mitzvahs i went to so that's
the other thing people don't realize how
like up in new york and and uh
everything new jersey i'm saying like
everybody like shared your cultures you
know like you had the latinos yeah you
got a friend
yeah everybody [ __ ] everybody uh
you know everybody live live with each
other but it was crazy i was watching on
netflix last night they had this series
for they're interviewing people who like
serio serial murderers what was that
word serial murderers uh-huh i guess
and uh this dude
ran like didn't go back to a halfway
house
he went back and just killed people ran
like he killed five people just randomly
just because he would drive by a house
and be like oh that house looks nice and
i'll go in there it was it was [ __ ] up
and then he it just happened like
i was thinking like how like your life
could have changed at that exact moment
absolutely all i needed was to bump into
a guy that i thought was cool
and who i thought was influential in
there you know the mad dog oh mad dog
and mad dog would sit there and tell you
stories about his days on the bike man
there's a guy up in pelican bay man
his name is brenner's man here he's a
stone cold killer we partied together a
couple of times he's
he's done about 16 years murder just and
you sit there going
what are you [ __ ] did you ever read
about abe lincoln
you know george washington is
you know who hitler is and mussolini
those are great men you know donna
summer and barbara streisand
some guy mad dog in some prison who man
that guy took on three guards man
we partied out together once they tell
you that you like listen it's over for
you
just go to the puerto rican side
hopefully they'll [ __ ] you to death
because you don't have a [ __ ] day
left in you once you get in the real
world if you're worried about mad dog is
the kid it is it's like a [ __ ]
coolest [ __ ] guy i've ever seen him i
remember one day when i was locked up
there was this guy that was johnny
everything
the metal rings
the lead jacket over the [ __ ] black
shirt
you know it was 87 he already had tats
he already had nobody moves their hair
he already moves their hair with the
little sunglasses because this place i
went to you could wear your own clothes
if you got a petition
and then i was sitting around with some
guys in there and the album of the year
was
animal appetite for destruction
and it's that mr brownstone i mean these
guys are talking about how
he wrote about heroin he came over he's
like it's not about [ __ ] heroin it's
about mr brownstone i did time with that
dude
and we're like what are you [ __ ] why
would guns and roses
sing a song about some dude in [ __ ]
kansas jail
mr brown what are you that's how
[ __ ] they get like man i partied out
with mr brownstone he met axel rose one
time and told him the story so axl rose
promised to me rather shut the [ __ ] up
you [ __ ] [ __ ] junkie what do you
think that [ __ ] guy is now a waxer
wrong no no
eating [ __ ] cheeseburgers with 20
bills between his [ __ ]
toenails
johnny bravo gotta hung out with the
[ __ ] guy with the the moose tear and
the and the jeans that [ __ ] wannabe
biker there was where i went there was a
little connection all these wannabe
bikers
there was this guy uh
that was something that dog or something
he was the leader of him he was like the
old guy that was a terrible nickname he
had killed somebody involuntary
manslaughter party and he had these
little minions that were all [ __ ]
the one guy smacked was one of his
minions a blind head dude that wore
gloves in the prison like there's not
even a tricycle in here why do you have
gloves on they're walking out with tight
gloves with their fingers out like why
get it to [ __ ] gather guys
i had a beef with him in the laundry
room and i tied his hair up
i grabbed him by the hand i just tied it
up with my hands and i banged his head
against the wall and i took a [ __ ] in
his drawer and one of those uh cheese
boxes
i took a long [ __ ] and i put it but
the point being it's it's you see those
guys when you're in there you shake
their hand you talk to them and you move
the [ __ ] down you don't want to talk to
those morons you don't want that [ __ ]
iq
just standing next to those guys you're
right
you knew me dawg he was a dumb [ __ ] and
i used to be a stock flick in the
kitchen so i took a [ __ ] in the toilet i
took it out complete
yeah the whole loaf the whole low stayed
together oh i thought you should in the
box you shipped it into the toilet and
then i pulled the box i think i shook
the box because it never broke
the [ __ ] was complete how crazy do you
have to be the [ __ ] in the box and it
was perfect because it was this thing it
was like a rose box that comes on how
many key eggs was it no no
you know what you know the
do you know the [ __ ] uh did you get
that south park reference or no no i
don't i don't do it i like to tell
parker what did he say remember when
[ __ ] measured the turd [ __ ] uh oh
yeah yeah
this was an american cheese box you know
those government cheese
i took a [ __ ] in there you know what
they put you know when you go to a diner
in the east coast and they put a flag on
the american flag on the blt or
something i took it out i get i have
these two they said i put that right in
the middle of this [ __ ] and i put the
box in this drawer behind his clothes
and everything he walk around the
barracks going man anybody smell [ __ ] or
is it just me and we would look at him
like oh this guy don't know it and he
figured it out one day and he saw the
box and he came into my room
man i knew it was you [ __ ] my [ __ ]
my cheese box i know it was you [ __ ] my
cheese box
there's some people that you beat in
life that do that [ __ ] to that they come
back and tell you
this one time i robbed this mexican kid
that was my roommate in boulder when i
first roofed the boat he just bothered
me him of these other three momos would
lip-sync
they were friends because they would
travel around and go to lip sync
competition in jail
no this is oh
okay okay i got you i moved to the hill
in boulder and there was three idiots
living in an apartment
and they would go to not lip syncing
contests air guitar contest no you live
with air guitar people oh please tell me
you [ __ ] in their cheese box no and the
mexican kid drove me crazy
he would always bother me man you can't
bring women over here and [ __ ] them at
night their mother shut the [ __ ] up i
brought two girls over there one was a
freak and one night he came to me and
knocked on my door so when this he left
and said what he kept
he was he was jealous so i went over but
i seen his door open and he was sleeping
dog tipped out in his room and i picked
up the town and there's a hundred dollar
bill i took of that
about a day later he kept knocking on my
door dog i worked in the sun for that
hundred dollar bill he kept saying to me
i'm like i spent a lot i didn't tell him
i spent it already but
i felt bad because i thought he was you
told him you're robbing though no then i
kept saying i don't know what you're
talking about okay
you never you never met anything i had
that saved up for a guitar competition
well don't look like you're going i'll
give you a dollar play the guitar in the
living room
they didn't get high they did nothing
brothers just play air guitar or air
guitar in the [ __ ] living room at
night
with no shirts or a japanese kid a
mexican and a white goofy [ __ ]
how did you find these guys i applied
for there was 200 a month the japanese
guy had on the payroll for a while he's
only paid for half your rent one month
i was giving the [ __ ] uh japanese guy
200 20 dollars a day to go to the store
alfalfa's cook and get food
and cook healthy food for why but he
would eat the other half
because i got a lost settlement i had
some dollars so i didn't want to cook i
didn't know how to cook and i got sick
and tired can you put the camera on
yourself i don't know what's up
talk so i used to pay him 20 bucks to go
down to alfalfa's buy half a pound of
meat some rice and vegetables and he
walk it up and he gives him to me and
some to him and he was a broke student
that's a good deal great [ __ ] deal
yeah strong deal and then but he was by
the [ __ ] book then the cops came they
knocked in the door they got mad then i
left the next day
i was dead for about a month and a half
before the cops came that's when i used
to do credit card [ __ ]
that was back in the day when you can
get away with that [ __ ] with the numbers
and the the [ __ ] uh click click they
used to sell the [ __ ] carbons
back into the [ __ ] carbons that's
right they give you the carbons that's
we had we had this guy at the at the don
carter's bowling alley
that when we were kids if we had carbons
he would take them and then he had this
plastic thing where you can [ __ ] make
the the mold
you know well we just gave the carbons i
remember this dude coming around we were
playing football one time asking if we
had fire extinguishers if we want to
make some money to get them fire
extinguishers we were kids
i'm like what the [ __ ] is we're getting
fire extinguishers for you know
and then uh we had this one this one one
kid of ours i don't like to throw the
names out i know i know you i don't i
don't know joey doesn't mind i know joe
doesn't mind but uh he went and got some
and i guess that
there you go
there you go
not for you and your [ __ ] names all
right
you know what was funny though do you
smell this whey protein fart right here
i'm sure it's way these are some [ __ ]
scallops backing up this is some
scallops mama made some [ __ ] fish
friday with some spa
remember when you farted on stage one
night i [ __ ] never laughed so hard in
my life he was at the store and he's
like hey uh hold on a second and then he
he went
he went
then he won science yeah and then it
went back in oh dude i was [ __ ] you
gotta stop and go hold on hold on
and then you fart they can't they can't
recover from that if you said you
stopped the fart was the science on top
of the phone oh please that's the
[ __ ] price you're not gonna fart and
not leave it out of the science that's a
whole [ __ ] patois the whole thing
lee what's up with you brother how you
feeling not as bad as you thought i'm
really [ __ ] up
are you going to drive you need a ride
no i got uber don't give him nothing
[ __ ] him he gets me all right
yeah that's his problem see he already
tapped out before he got it i should tie
him up dude it's [ __ ] intense saint
patrick's day the cops are going to be
out [ __ ] someone take it come back
every hour and put it on backwards until
his head blows up that's what i should
do but you're lucky i spoil you and i
love you
if not i can spoil you tie you up and
toughen you up and you're sucking with
that whose vacuum is that mine where'd
you get that [ __ ] thing from it's
mine we haven't vacuumed in here since
we've moved in here thank you for
vacuuming you're a good [ __ ] man
you're welcome i'll tell you those some
[ __ ] great pictures
little charlotch bronson and [ __ ]
clint eastwood
[ __ ]
uncle joey [ __ ] up there
[ __ ] that [ __ ] no i'm very happy i grew
up like i did at times and i'm happy i
had that little hustle now i sit here
sometimes
i look at this two-year-old little girl
and i'm trying to figure out how to
explain it to her i would wait
no you have to [ __ ] wait but i don't
think i'll be alive i'm joking
every [ __ ] day you know it's one less
heartbeat
oh no
i mean you're taking good care of
yourself so you know you try you try you
drink water you don't you you spray on
butter like this [ __ ] mortar you're
mad at me freezing spray butter today
you save a lot of calories
actually real butter is better for you
it's better
because it's more natural oh yeah the
margarine [ __ ] will kill you i told you
it's all chemicals
here's what i want you to do he goes
home makes tortellini and put spray-on
butter on it what the [ __ ] the purpose
this is what i'm it defeats its purpose
this is what i'm [ __ ] saying bring it
over here but everybody says no you're
being hard on them i'm trying to [ __ ]
no more spread lee listen i want you to
google paleo diet okay all right follow
that it'll save your life what don't you
eat you just don't eat grains no breads
no [ __ ] no
no none of that [ __ ] and no [ __ ]
no dairy but you can eat raw meat
chicken wings but it's it's supposed to
be like you know how many chicken wings
that's the clinker for you you can eat a
[ __ ] you can eat 30 if you want like
so we can start the paleo diet right
after that
that's absolutely right go right to big
wings right down the street you can't
eat fried chicken wings and just not eat
cheese and lose weight that's what you
do listen to me look it up look it up
i'll look it up but you can't eat fried
things you know what yeah i don't like
naysayers yes you can you can eat
chicken
you can't you can't eat the [ __ ] blue
cheese either no you can't do that you
gotta eat those then what's the point i
know that's the thing that'll you lose a
lot of between you gotta go and eat with
[ __ ] celery right you can eat celery
eat the celery and carrots oh mashed
potatoes no no potatoes
sweet potatoes you if you're gonna cheat
like they they recommend like one day
you just [ __ ] you know get it out of
here what do you do for carbs
they use vegetables man it's real simple
carbs man those are the best because the
grains the way that the grains are
they're ground seeds and and you know
seeds are not really so no whole grain
no no
but if you're going to go the whole
grain pasta i do brown like when i when
i do my cheat i do brown rice i lost uh
i lost about eight pounds
i don't give a [ __ ] about brown rice i
hate brown rice no but they have brown
rice listen to me brown rice pasta what
am i doing
you know they have brown rice pasta from
trader joe's good it's [ __ ] good man
it's good really yeah yeah yeah i'll try
it i don't try i've
yeah but see here's the thing is that if
you if you do the brown rice pasta
that's when you you don't want to eat
any grains but if you're gonna do it
sweet potatoes are good uh baked
potatoes are good and brown rice pasta
is good you know but just do it like
once a week yeah once a week on a sunday
at two o'clock nights
after church like a doctor's like a
[ __ ] job i don't even want meat sauce
no more my wife makes a little marinara
nice little spicy to it you're good
you're [ __ ] good i eat that i got me
yeah let me get some [ __ ] shout outs
and get this party started let's do it i
met a really nice pick my wife up tell
your wife to relax i met a really nice
[ __ ] girl
i made a picture for us what i didn't
bring and she gave me a lighter
and she had a smile that would [ __ ]
her and her husband came jennica jones i
love you to death up in sacramento
harold [ __ ] i love you i'm sorry
about your mom but hang in there
[ __ ] you're a big boy now grab
your balls
just think of your mom every day and go
out there and [ __ ] somebody in the ass
that's how it's done
hi mate jordan i love you shut the [ __ ]
up
brayden marsley
crazy michelle hurley
i don't know who the [ __ ] this is burke
happy recovery much love cox sucker mike
wilson junior bobby sharon and your
beautiful girlfriend and david represent
i got you [ __ ] now what what's up
buddy you see that picture i tweeted you
[ __ ] at the arizona scottsdale no no
they got the picture you at the house of
comedy it's [ __ ] nice come on yeah
it's right where you going to the men's
room
i think i saw my twitter somewhere they
always put you near the men's room yeah
he's cute come in his big [ __ ] nice
uncle joey picture you [ __ ] faded in
nice it's kind of yeah it's huge it's
like the size of that come on your
little [ __ ] joey collage
oh my god see that yeah how are you
feeling lee not bad i'm good i'm [ __ ]
up but i'm good glad i uber
nah
yeah you could go out there and drive
like a savage that's [ __ ] i don't
know what you're scared of [ __ ] a
ten thousand dollar dui you're not gonna
get no duis you're as tough as nails
what's coming what's coming up for you
man i know the other day we spoke you
said your pilot didn't get picked up you
shot a pilot from home no i was with nbc
and then it didn't get picked up so you
know what was the pilot it was called
mason twins between that was last year
while you were shooting it did you
really think you had a chance because i
wasn't shooting them i'm like well
here's what's that man here's the sad
part it's uh uh you know it did get
picked up there was a lot of
anticipation about it it was like well
you know the one you know they say it's
a good one
but the kid that um
uh the black kid the heavy black kid
that just passed away the kid from
miller like commercials
he was in there and uh he was he was
with us in it and uh dude it was sad to
see him die man that kid that kid was
[ __ ]
every time he opened his mouth he was
funny he was funny man where was he from
uh he's from houston he was a trained
actor uh what did he die from i don't
know i don't know
it's scary like that's why sometimes i
get down about uh going to the gym but
he was 36.
it didn't look like it i mean he could
have been but like that's why like
keep going because like yeah he was 36
he was young yeah he was a young dude
man it's it's it's really weird when you
shoot a pilot and your hopes and
aspirations are up and they're telling
you that you got a chance and
then you're going you're thinking in
your mind all the different scenarios
and you're gonna get picked up as a
[ __ ] recurring
now i was booked as a regular and then
the year before that i had one with gary
cole you know the guy from uh office
space and uh talladega nights
[ __ ] very talented actor and uh that
was another one that yeah what network
was that that was for fox and then and i
had a talk show for e that same year and
that's what people don't realize you
know i'm looking at if both those things
go i'm looking at a you know damn near
seven figure year going from you know
did you shoot the pilot forward i shot
them both yeah and what was the e talk
show about it was this was years ago it
was like a it was a relationship show it
was a me a gay dude a straight chick and
a lesbian so it was pretty much three
chicks in me and then we gave him
[ __ ] picked up
now no no i didn't have pimples
we were giving it relationship advice it
was it was you know it was a good time
man i mean look some of these shows you
do you're like
you know you can say no you know i can
read a script and say i don't want to do
it
um and you know you try and pick the
ones that you think are doing with the
same agent that dude or you left them i
i'm with uh don buckwald now i went over
there they're real good yeah yeah good
job for everything yeah yeah man
that's really good that you
i popped five pilots in a row
well chappelle had like 13 right before
one i remember when i first moved to
they were giving chappelle tons of money
chappelle had one with the dude from
talk soup that went on to become a big
star right here great canary that didn't
get picked up i mean
i mean they weren't my pilots i just
shot them i shot what got me here was a
big cop show on cbs
with what's his name directing it was a
shoot one it was their answer to the
nypd blue didn't get picked up
the only one that got picked up that
they didn't hire me after was the lewis
guzman show i shot nypd blue 2069 what
the new york would be like in the year
2069.
i shot a happy hour from the people from
the what's the [ __ ] show or what's
the the two [ __ ] idiots now that
replaced uh what's his name on the
[ __ ] show
i have no idea what you're talking about
i'll i'll figure it out now what's the
two two and a half baby who replaces
that men ashton kutcher what show did he
come from that's how many shows the same
writers on the 70s show rap this was the
next hot show the chick went and bought
a house the show got canceled after four
episodes
so i've been involved in all those and
it's it's it's a good little hope it
keeps you hoping but then you said
something beautiful with me the other
night you go you know what now i'm back
on the road where i belong and i love it
and you love it stand-up's my 401k and
it's what i love you know it's what i do
it's what i love at the end of the day
that's the thing you can't take that
away from us you amass an audience
you could say what you want to say
and be as expressive as possible you
know and um and still try and make a
living you know i mean 35 weeks a year
takes its toll i'd like to be hitting
those theaters i would like to do friday
saturday i'm doing 35 weeks absolutely
man i mean every i just left birmingham
i leave for denver on wednesday
so you're doing a hustle three weeks a
month yeah yeah pretty much man no [ __ ]
yeah you're still in a relationship
absolutely but then i got to go get my
wife now go get it
i love you thank you where are you at
this weekend uh this weekend i'm at
comedy works in denver okay uh not
downtown the one in um
the suburb one which is the green they
got in the black man
with the thing the whole thing is to
jump up and down call me if you get
locked up man we'll come get you okay no
i love you brother
thank you very much for coming on
i love you guys give me a hug all right
let me go get leah stay black give lee a
big hug he needs it look at him look at
him he could tell in his eyes he needs
the biggest hug ever he's in shock [ __ ]
next week we're doing heroin on the
[ __ ] show next monday we're going to
end it i love you love you buddy thank
you very much
yeah i don't want to do heroin
you got to do something once
yeah uh uh check me out just go to
breaders.com b-r-e-t-e-r-n-s-t
dot com uh it's called the bread earned
show but we just do like top ten lists
and argue stupid [ __ ] i gotta have you
on okay top ten [ __ ] uh disco artists
of all time keep me posted sylvester's
number two
the black [ __ ] from [ __ ] wherever he's
from i love that [ __ ] you make
me feel
mighty real in fact that's what we're
closing with tonight what's happening
you bad [ __ ] uh sacramento i
had a great time this last week i'm
sorry i didn't mention you guys it
really was great
the week before was in cleveland this
last three week uh
got [ __ ] i was tired but you guys
made it great thank you very much for
being great audiences and this thursday
night do not forget i'm on
the last this is not happening with ari
shafir i need this favor for you guys to
dvr there's a personal favorite for me
hopefully they'll see that there's
[ __ ] action here and they'll put me
on comedy central a lot more but it's up
to you guys do me that [ __ ] salad huh
it's a good story
yeah you know uh it was a heartfelt
story that i hid for a long time
i always had people go yeah but you had
it hard you grew up on the streets no i
had a little bit of help
and uh i did what i could with it and i
always i never forgot who she was
but the story was beautiful that she was
my mother's friend
she made a promise to my mother in the
casket and she [ __ ] did a lot of
people can't keep a promise when people
are alive
never mind when people are dead to judge
them you know so
uh at the end things happen how they did
and i always felt guilty about that so
me saying the story
is my i'm sorry to her whatever the [ __ ]
she is you know what i'm saying why are
you fidgeting for lee everything all
right guys that's what makes it sounds
cool it sounds cool don't worry about
none stop fidgeting i'm talking to you
moving around how you feeling good i'm
really [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah you're [ __ ]
up and i feel good too but that's the
story on thursday night talking
i appreciate plus i want ari's show to
get picked up it's not even about me or
whatever i want every show that gets
picked up this is a great idea it always
has been and uh
it's up to you guys to keep it on the
air so do me a favor this is not
happening on comedy central put it on
your [ __ ] dvr and they have it on
youtube if you don't have cable you can
watch it on on comedycentral.com or on
youtube so that's the tell them that why
don't you tell them that they're not
supposed to know that i'm trying to know
what's good if they don't have cables
but who gives a [ __ ] these people have
cable not everything you want to sell
okay this was a marketing thing you
never give them the aftermath i need
them to turn the dvr on okay you follow
me i don't need them to aftermath i
thought the other one they were no you
didn't think i'm telling them right now
i don't want i want i need for them to
turn the dvr on okay yeah i don't need
for them to go on comedycenter.com
i need for them to turn the [ __ ] dvr
on that's what gets more viewers that
will get his show picked up i didn't
know okay but what the [ __ ]
sit there and stare at the microphone
you did for two hours before you were
sitting there like it's a black dick
coming at you i had to go over a couple
of times and go what the [ __ ] you
looking at [ __ ]
so please turn the dvr on and don't
listen to [ __ ] jamock over here don't
listen to me the next day you could turn
the [ __ ] comedy central that night
just turn the dvr on even if you [ __ ]
erase it the next day
you understand i feel i feel you i
understand where i was coming from
there's a method to my madness like you
see me over here on the mushroom you try
to interrupt me you get me off my
[ __ ] thought you know how i'm feeling
i'm feeling how you're [ __ ] feeling
[ __ ]
i don't think that's far what's up i'm
not even the 6 000 milligram star
take a bite of that [ __ ]
it's monday i love you guys let me give
some spot out shout outs to the
to these great sponsors irondragontv.com
listen they got a ultrafix 4k ultra
network on there so you can watch some
of them [ __ ] martial art films
you should see lee's eyeballs right now
you can watch that martial art films in
4k already yeah i don't know how many
movies are there but it's [ __ ]
tremendous they're more coming everybody
have the mandarin magician
i got brian cushing's [ __ ] shoulder
exercises i got a bunch of [ __ ] on that
on iron dragon tv they just don't do
just classic martial arts i mean that's
the main reason to [ __ ] go there you
know what i'm saying do me a favor go to
irondragontv.com right now and press in
joey boom and what do you got lee you
get two free movies jesus [ __ ] christ
on the crotch two free movies just to
get the party started correct have you
been on iron drive i have i i just got
he just gave me uh i just went and got
my roku it's awesome they have and and
they have a bunch of free ones which are
really cool if you like a bunch of the
older stuff but then use your code on
some of the new stuff they have a bunch
of new like tai chi hero that one he
always shows us when we go right it's
great it looks really good yeah the 4k
technology is [ __ ] sensational you
know it's not on all the movies yet but
iron dragon tv is the way to go what do
they press joey stop scratching your
head and get two free movies honey.com
what do you call it top optimization
they're now available in whole foods
they just did it
you know i remember when these guys were
[ __ ] nothing now look at them and the
only reason why they grew is because
their products [ __ ] work and i give
you an opportunity to get 10 off on
everything they have except the weights
and the ropes and if you want to jump
over [ __ ] laws and [ __ ] but as far as
the minerals are concerned i got you
covered [ __ ] ten percent off go to
honor.com right now look at all the
great minimals they have i mean i'm sick
and tired of [ __ ] telling you this
from alpha brain godly he's gonna say
alphabrine.com
from alpha brain to [ __ ] new mood to
shroom tech they got the [ __ ] that
killed kennedy you understand me so do
me a favor go to [ __ ] go to [ __ ]
honor.com right now and press in church
to get 10 off your first order and 10
off many orders to come stay on it stay
on it program which means they mail it
right to your house directly every month
you don't have to do dick just give them
your credit card number nobody's going
to steal it maybe some russians in
bulgaria what do you care american
express pays that debt
nailed the life.com i was just at those
[ __ ] savages this weekend
the best [ __ ] pipe best vaper [ __ ]
pen on the market twenty percent off
when you order through the website these
two guys are great guys i know what the
[ __ ] they're doing give them a shot go
to iron uh i injured nailed the line
nailed it like dot com right now and
pressing joey diaz boom and get 20 off
your first order with a guarantee a
spring break something happens you call
dave they [ __ ] ship it to you no
drama also 86 how can you lose with
these [ __ ] i've been smoking
this cigar all night for a minute there
i thought it was in havana on the set of
godfather too but meanwhile i'm sitting
here with a [ __ ] little
my little jew from the valley it's not
nor hyman raw but [ __ ] it he's my hymen
rot and that's all that matters and [ __ ]
leaking out information to you [ __ ]
momos
anyway go to 86.com 0 8 16 24 milligrams
they got you covered with the nicotine
levels if you want to smoke a cigar this
is the way to go 1200 [ __ ] pups
guaranteed on each product 1200 pups a
hooker with [ __ ]
dental hygiene can't suck 1200 [ __ ]
pups out of nothing this cigarette gives
you 1200 [ __ ] electronic [ __ ] pups
go to 86.com and press in joey's church
boom and get 20 off your first order
it's 20 you get it for 16. all right
who's better than [ __ ] me
on it iron dragon tv nailed it life.com
and hit e6 i want to thank my sponsors
what's up cox what do you got going on
next week for this week i got nothing
i'm tripping on the mushroom and drink
some coffee and smoke some weed with you
you're not hungry
no we're gonna smoke some ash then we'll
get it i'm not smoking ham come on dog i
have some weed for you i got a piece of
ass why don't you want to
okay all right let's let's at least go
through the list of what i had today
what'd you have was goomy's hermanos
half a star no you didn't have a half a
star i had a quarter of a star i gave
you a little
40 million i gave you one little
sergeant straight oh
yes and then half of those goombies
which is what when you're one half of
gourmet and then i gave you your booger
mushrooms i gave you a little piece of
my the mushroom was strong oh i know
it's strong
that's right no [ __ ] no [ __ ] spray
butter no more i'm going to your house
tomorrow that's not better be there i
just got a new bottle you did you're
disgusting you know that i don't know
why you eat that [ __ ] you got a [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the bleeding i've always used
spray water since when
my mom always used to get it oh jesus
christ what i mean she got better
sometimes but this is my idea when the
[ __ ] grew up on spring but you
know what i'm saying
[ __ ] grew up on spray button you
people see why i'm getting older by
every day i gotta go dye my [ __ ] hair
for a commercial i got this [ __ ] guy
i'm trying to [ __ ] take under my wing
to become a future savage killer
oh so was it did you just find no not
yet what was that nothing i don't know
what do you say i gotta deal with look
at
smacking them and hitting them with his
dick in the face he's going to be
giggling but that's always what you say
you say i have to give you these edibles
in case isis comes over and steals like
what is isis going to make me do all
these edibles
because that's what they do before you
kill you get information from you but
you're already used to it your levels of
thc are high you're just going to tell
isis to suck your dick
and spit in their face like tony montana
in the shower scene i'm saying wow
they're selling that house
they're selling that house so buy it
what are you telling me like 30 million
dollars [ __ ] put it on your tab you
got a bunch of money i love you
[ __ ] don't forget about me
uh where am i this weekend nowhere i'm
[ __ ] home how's that for you do me a
favor on thursday night turn on your dvr
don't worry about at least yeah [ __ ]
what i said no tommy essential oil you
go on youtube the next day go [ __ ]
yourself i need you to turn the dv on
march 9th turn your neighbor's dvr on
yeah tell the neighbors even if they
don't like joey diaz and ari turn the
[ __ ] thing on either they don't like
joey diaz do me that favor right
anything else lee you want to tell these
[ __ ] people no i'm f i want to tell
them i'm [ __ ] up [ __ ] balls all day
yeah that's my job i love you guys thank
you for watching the church and what's
happening now we'll be back thursday at
two o'clock with stephen bow
going to on it what's the music on
consecutive i am
and we got one more started we're going
money into the snow we gotta eat another
stuff oh you're so crazy look at this
[ __ ] thing
i know six thousand milligrams don't
even open that oh i know that's not the
success of my grandmother oh this smells
just like
oh it smells crazy
put it up to the camera
i did look at how many
you're [ __ ] killing me two o'clock
thursday okay five o'clock east coast
time five seconds
look at this
all right [ __ ] turn him off and him
off all right i also want to give a
shout out
to axes rolling papers these are a
little broach clip they sent us we're
going to try them out this weekend
that's it you're going to say goodbye i
was trying to but then he kept saying
this is what about the [ __ ]
hello goodbye nothing for these people
i'm trying to but you keep talking i
ain't talking about it
all right
go to onyx.com and use codeword church
to get 10 off of all their optimization
products why is your voice cracking like
michael jackson because i'm trying to
say this and not freak out freak
yeah i'm really high
okay
go to honor.com and get
i was gonna roll there too no i don't
want to smoke this hatch
use cobra church to get 10 off all their
optimization products
go to nailed it life.com and get 20 off
of your order when you use cobra joey
diaz on the premiere vapor pen on the
market go to hit ecigs.com let's hit
esigs.com better tasting longer lasting
the proof is in the vape you get 20 off
when you go to hidesigs.com and use
codeword joey's church
and go to irondragontv.com the new the
new roku channel
with 4k technology use code where joey
get two free rentals